[Musique]
les marins shadoks ont embarqué sur leur
statut au lieu de remonter dans leurs
bateaux les autres sont montés à
l'assaut
la bataille fait rage
[Musique]
aux pauvres bêtes
les marins se défendirent d'assez
galamment mais à la fin il succombe air
sous le poids d'un adversaire très
supérieur en armement et en nous et on
leur dit que ce n'était pas parce que
j'étais revenu qu'on allait démolir est
si jolis monuments on l'a déconstruit
respect pour eux et qu'il était de leur
devoir eux les marins de disparaître
effectivement et ce le plus des signes
tivement possible
[Musique]
alors le marin shadoks se fit corsaire
de l'espace est dit que fois de shadocks
et voix de marins ils reviendraient
et qu'il se vengerait
[Musique]